من جهتها اكدت حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه ان
الرد الفلسطيني على اغتيال ثلاثه قاده من
سرايا القدس وعدد كبير من المدنيين لن
يتاخر ان سرايا القدس والمقاومه لن تتهاون
ابدا امام هذه الدماء وقد حملت الحركه
قاده الاحتلال كامل المسؤوليه عن هذه
الاغتيالات وقالت انها مثلت انتهاكا خطيرا
لوقف اطلاق النار واشددت حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي على ان الاحتلال لن يحقق اهدافه
من هذه العمليه واكدت سنان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه موحده ومواقفها الثابته
قال المتحدث هو باسم حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه ان المعاناه الفلسطينيه لن تكون
جسرا لوصول الاحتلال الى جمهوره
الاسرائيليه واضاف في مداخله سابقا مع
الجزيره ان كل السيناريوهات والخيارات
مفتوحه امام المقاومه للرد على جرائم
الاحتلال
ونحن نودع
نؤكد لاننا لم نستسلم لن نستلاح سنواجه
هذا الاحتلال لن تكون المعاناه الفلسطينيه
يسرا للوصول للجمهور الاسرائيلي نحن نؤكد
بان الاحتلال كان وهو من يتحمل المسؤوليه
الكامله
ترد بكل سنريوهات والخيارات هي مفتوحه وكل
الادوات والوسائل من اجل التاكيد على
الروايه الوطنيه الفلس